for a long time in my life I was a drug
addict with nothing right and yeah I was
never used to having any money and now
um 7 and a half years clean and so I
decided to you know treat myself and get
the car that I wanted after down payment
the amount financed is 26,000 okay how
much do you make a
year um after taxes I take home about 96
Grand it's not an insane number compared
to your income like if you were making
$30,000 I'd have to tell you you have to
sell this but you could probably pay it
off pretty quickly I would I would do
what I could to pay that that car debt
off um as soon as possible yeah that's
what I'm thinking I I think I could get
it paid off comfortably in the next I
mean if I take that money out and I put
it towards the car probably six months
yeah I get it PA off easily